tiffany bon moi je pense à vous ce matin
que c est pourquoi pourquoi ce qu'on
vous a imité chaussée vous l'avez
entendu maintenant mais le président de
votre radio m'a envoyé l'extrait a c'est
vrai oui mais on imitait bien que l'on
brasse mais oui ça vous a plu
vous voyez ça beaucoup j'adore yann
jamet et elle était très l'imitatrice
elle aussi est ce que vous voulez voir
un petit d'imitatrice puisqu'on est sûre
m radio en scanner sa cible mais non
c'est gras dur reconnaît avait pas un
truc plus tard carla bruni incarnant la
ccia pdc fait carla bruni rapide dans la
semaine merci j'ai quelqu'un pour vous
que j'avais avec qui vous pourriez vous
réconcilier et vous allez trouver
clairière en banon mais séries tu pas
contente
[Rires]
tout est là c'est karine lemarchand télé
rires arrêté c'est exactement
voyez comme quoi la france n'a pas
toujours un incroyable talent